what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
clip from the fit and fresh
podcast titled who hurt this girl
i know a lot of girls that have been
hurt so
i could probably tell you before i start
to not forget to like comment and
subscribe
especially subscribe trying to get to 15
000 subscribers
as you know each and every one of you
helps me get to that goal
all right i like their intro
which one uh oh jordan grass what would
the ladies tell their own sons on how to
deal with modern women this is actually
a phenomenal question
that's a good one that's good all right
uh we'll start with uh
with um egypt yeah you have nice eyes by
the way
oh thank you i would a hundred percent
if this was a porno do a money shot
there but
wait is that watching this that's
watching oh my god
what have i gotten myself into it just
it's so
awkward like that's so cringe like that
word
listen listen listen okay um yeah what'd
you tell your son
oh i would i okay i really don't want to
raise a [ __ ] boy
oh and i probably will that's like the
problem i think
because there's many definitions for it
right so like i think about a guy who
thinks they're just too pretty
right just can't react with any girl
and
[Laughter]
uh no but like but like i don't know
some i want a guy you know i want my son
to respect women i think that's
important
but hold on it's okay like if he's
confident if he wants to have sex with a
bunch of women it's okay
but just like treat women with respect
that's important
respect is a problem i mean i'm sorry
what part of that did you not like
i i did it i did it by accident oh right
totally
yeah all right all right no i mean i
wanna i wanna keep it real with him like
it's okay
like if you wanna come to me and talk to
me about things like but don't you think
by him being a nice guy that he'll get
taken to the cleaners
he will not be he won't a knife a nice
guy oh okay
okay he won't be no oh there you go guys
see mama's gonna train him
but there is there's a middle ground and
that's what people
miss there's a way to be a nice guy
without
getting walked all over not
mommy's gonna train him listen it's i
mean it is a chase
right it's about you can you can be a
player whatever but just treat women
with respect it's important
do not i don't know what to hit right
now well listen respect is important
come on chivalry is not dead
i'm not dead no i don't know charles
what do you think
chivalry's dead and women killed it why
did they kill it though
that's true that's true i agree with
that
like there's a bunch of women that are
like i can hold my own door i can pay
for my own stuff
i'm like nah why why would you ruin this
for all of us
like guys we had free food we didn't
have to work
we had a good thing going
a lot of girls messed it up they're like
oh we want to do all this stuff i'm like
do we
do we really cause i was cool just
chilling but
feminism feminism right because you know
what happened right and tony robbins
talks about this i'm not giving him a
shout out i'm just saying here we go
did you guys have this discussion before
after school emasculate
right like a guy yeah he's gonna become
more feminine
he's not gonna like want to provide he's
not gonna want to be like the
you know the macho man right i would
argue if you're able to emasculate him
then you pick the wrong guy in the first
place well that right and that's true
but in some ways it's not because the
more you
put you know a guy down make him feel
like less
he becomes more feminine and then the
relationship is polarized
and it's awful because the woman then
has to wear pants
and that's the mother's side and that's
a problem right a lot of that
mothers are like that exactly right so
you have to live in the feminine
you have to be submissive you have to
okay you have to have that right because
that's what like that
but what are women's question for the
comments what are women supposed to do
when i would say in 2021 there really
aren't as many like masculine men
as there were before so what do women do
when you know obviously
there's only so many guys only so many
are masculine
what are they supposed to do when maybe
they can't get a masculine guy
that's what drives men it's important
it's like caveman you know what i mean
like
the girl goes out she gets the berries
and like
oh my god i hope that this is like okay
i've had
yeah anyway um it's okay
we'll tell them that we told you to say
this no but listen it's important right
the man needs to provide
and the woman has to let him do that
wait let let be hot listen
he needs to be masculine when i'm when i
say let
i'm saying like hey like it's okay like
i wanna i want that
protection i want that strong masculine
side
has to i wanna be provided for i'll tell
you this guys it's important and that is
what empowers the man
when the woman says hey like you're you
can be in here
right but she's still there you know
what i mean like working the decisions
and she could be wearing the pants but
she
lets him have some of that is it the let
word is that's what's really getting no
i mean
i always tell guys like this bro i ain't
cuban but when you deal with women you
got to become fidel castro you are now
the dictator my friends
he's currently saying like you're giving
him permission
yeah right but but it's okay to give i
feel like it's a i'm trying to think
i would not say like my parents have
been married
27 years and i would not say like it's
like the type of marriage or whatever my
dad says
says goes like it's very much they both
have like an input
but they both like kind of do their own
thing okay to give a guy permission
but like it i don't know it's hard
permission assumes that you're an
authority which you're not
women don't lead men leaders hey listen
come on
come on men lead women followers i know
what you're saying you're just using
buzzwords that we tell people that you
don't like
right okay and then right so you're
giving him permission
but you i mean you've been on point
other than that
okay saying yeah yeah that guy's just
nitpicking the right things you have to
be feminine you have to live in that no
guy should be taking that on you you
don't even mean like in that kind of
relationship you have to like have that
and that's what drives the man it's so
important okay
in other words
man egypt was so good at articulating
nothing that we forgot what the question
is
for real all day
i think i'm going to hire you
diplomat we were talking about um
raising sons oh yeah raising sons yeah
yeah raising sons
how would you raise your sons um to deal
with modern day women remember
modern day women guard your heart
okay because most men that become [ __ ]
boys is because a woman broke their
heart or did something shitty to them
are you telling me that players are made
from women not accepting chivalry
yes
[Music]
we'll see if he comes i was just curious
to see
what he would say if
okay do you think that play like
guys that are players are made
because of women
really why you think they like met a
girl that's
like evil and they become a player
because it is necessarily that in every
case
but in 99 of the cases
when they show men why they shouldn't
love these hoes
interesting so like the biggest players
don't love these hoes
baby no relationship 20 21. baby we're
dating [ __ ] [ __ ] get money
and act like you didn't know
the girls run all over him they use them
they finesse them
and then when they foodie dates and then
they use them for foodie dates and then
when they make a youtube video
who hurt you yeah well but you hurt that
guy because they know
cause she knows he needs to be confident
right in himself
right and that's okay that's important
but like [ __ ]
yeah i'm recording interrupting you a
little bit
i thought you just don't want to take
time for your bro i was out there like
45 minutes
well it took me a while to set
everything up and then you were still
out there so i was like okay i'll just
make a video
so what am i supposed to do do you want
me to stop what i'm doing
to pay attention to you
boys arrogance it's i don't care about
the world i don't care about who i hurt
whatever that's not cool
you know what i mean and i agree with
you
so women create [ __ ] boards women
they do they really do in a way you
created your own problem
so you say women the women right right
earlier sometimes men put themselves in
that situation too by being a good guy
they try to be children yes
they try to be knighted out you see it
and you're like all right
i'll go out with them and then you use
them and then you
below one more thing real quick real
quick one thing that uh
that that our diplomat are you okay with
yeah god
sorry go ahead cj you're gonna say
something yeah show me to the bank uh
back blown out right blown out
this would be the first tips might be
you know they wild i think
yeah they what you're cuban
i'm innocent
wait what about you nessie about having
a raising kid must be
messed up by girls what would you do
thank you jess blaze thank you
what's your spicy nose says don't
misunderstand what she's saying she says
allow you to lead but allow she means
take a step back
and follow his leadership yeah just
blaze is definitely going to send you a
dick pic later
i'm trying to warm it up
wants one kid and wants to be a power
couple that's a bad deal for the child
since he or she will be neglected due to
work
due to two work schedules and a bad deal
for most men who want more than one kid
bree what do you got to say to that
okay so i'm open to negotiation
i grew up with nannies it's really not
that bad about that
i mean i mean what happens happens right
but i'm just like shooting for one kid
for now
um but in a relationship i think it's
important that you
have i i want to have financial freedom
you know when i'm in a relationship and
i want him to be able to have the same
and when i was a kid
my parents traveled with me and did a
lot of things with me and i don't know
no oh you weren't how many brother
sisters you got i have one brother and
two sisters
okay okay and a step brother are you oh
stop [ __ ] okay
yeah well real real quick uh when you're
in a marriage i don't know if you guys
know this
but uh you're together here i am there's
no such thing as independent or freedom
oh i mean like well traveling and things
like that i know but but you said you
would like to have financial freedom
right you're talking about together well
as an individual no together right so
like
i actually agree i feel like couples
should have one bank account
but there's no fight there's no look
when you marry there's no freedom
there's no freedom what do you mean when
if you look up the word marriage you're
blind you're co-mingling you come
together
so i don't understand that concept it's
a feminist concept
mind you but i don't understand the
concept of people coming in
saying well this is gonna be mine and
i'm gonna have this
okay just two cents i would say that
concept
comes from women basically giving up
their careers to raise kids and ending
up divorced and then
not having like a career to go back on i
understand that like men
are like women a lot of times get more
like money than the men do
in court but i've
like i could see the like case for
having financial freedom just to not put
yourself in a position where something
didn't work out
um that you would not have a career to
go back on
just in case there is no way in hell
people can come out here and make that
work it just it just doesn't make sense
but people are conditioned to believe
that for their own
selfish purposes but you can't get
married for selfish purposes
that's not the definition of it so
absolutely it's one of the reasons why
marriages don't work
right people are coming in saying well i
want to be able to have my freedom i
want to be able to be independent
i want to be able to have well marriage
is not going to work it's all
it's already doing from the start so
that's that's not that's not what i'm
saying
and that but that's a valid point um i
think that
it's important to have the financial
freedom to be able to do the things you
want to do together
that's what i'm saying i'm saying
together right so like we want to travel
we want to expose our kid to you know
different cultures and experiences and
things that i was able to enjoy as a kid
um i think that's quite important and
that they can explore any kind of you
know thing they
enjoy right any passion they have i want
to be able to support that and help that
flourish like my parents
like a muddy she has a really good voice
i'm sorry but she has a really good
guys that's the end of the video let me
know what you guys think of the comments
do you think
that players are made or do you think
they're just
you know like that from the get-go
before i end the video do not forget to
like comment and subscribe
i will talk to you guys next time